j'ai 4 ans et demi j'en suis mal voyons
les ou toi t'es pas mal voyants on est
des vieux os à fait partie des des
pathologies qui sont rares donc s'est
associé à un taux maladies orphelines
ça se développe à très tôt pendant
l'enfance en intra utérin et ça entraîne
en fait une malformation du système
nerveux central
donc une malformation des maires au pied
bien évident tracas il a aussi en
associés dans une malformation de son
lit peaufineront qu'il a aussi des
troubles en ce moment qui va avoir ravi
en fait parce qu'ils ont mené comme ça
et donc il a les déficiences visuelles
sévère il boit at on tout petit peu des
petites choses mais la ffr une image
globale de ce qu'ils voient donc c'est
pour ça qu'il va apprendre le braille
c'est pour ça qu'ils utilisent une canne
qui commencent à utiliser une canne pour
se déplacer comme les aspects de la
scène
on a débuté au mois d'octobre
l'année dernière dont c'est la première
année scolaire que je vis chain donc
voilà on a découpé par l'apprentissage
de l'après talent avant la canne blanche
et là ça fait à peine car comme l'a
commenté ma professeur de latin où il
avait battu contre les autres moi et
donc voilà donc c'est pas mal pour un
début
et les obstacles à un point fixe via
l'arop et la photo où les trains exemple
hélas hélas pour rencontre
à mon âge et on n'a pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait de se retrouver en situation de
handicap c'est assez compliqué pour une
famille il ya tout un tas de démarches à
réaliser
elle compte pas forcément simple et il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
familles qui sont vraiment en difficulté
là dessus on est un petit peu seul face
à ça à cette espèce de montagne de
dossiers administratifs à monter dans
tous les sens
nous on a pu le faire et puis on a
réussi à avoir probablement vraiment une
un contexte d' est bien adapté à ses
besoins elle et avs en fait et elle
moque elle s'occupe de moi
si j'arrive pas faire des choses joachim
il est accompagné par une avs à temps
plein à l'école qui couvre les temps
scolaires mais ce qui couvre aussi les
temps périscolaires parce que la douceur
visuel n'entraîne pas que des
difficultés pour les apprentissages
scolaires et par contre entraîne aussi
tout un tas de retard d'acquisition dans
le développement psychomoteur et tout ce
qui est l'autonomie au quotidien par
exemple près de manger de sa vie d aller
aux toilettes c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué donc il
nécessite aussi un abs là dessus
[Musique]
l'annnonce du handicap a été très
violent en fait à l'hôpital au début non
joachim vous inquiétez pas il y aura
rien deux mois après il semble qu'il ya
un souci
un mois encore après non ne vous
inquiétez pas ça a duré huit mois en
tout et dernier coup on nous dit oui
mais un gros souci et on nous annonce
par téléphone que je dois à kim et non
voyants alors c'est ça on est un petit
peu parce qu'il est que mal voyants mais
voilà c'est ça s'est fait par téléphone
et souvent les l'annnonce du handicap en
fait aux parents est super bien avec
toutes les peines tous les parents que
j'ai rencontré il annonce a toujours été
mal fait ou on prend pas le temps un
petit peu de poser les choses quoi il
faut se dire que des premières paroles
d'un con quand vous annoncez votre show
est en situation de handicap
c'est les choses qui resteront gravées
vraiment dans la tête quoi les enfants à
l'école de l'orage il n'y a pas trop de
regard
entre malveillants ou trop bienveillants
j'ai envie de dire quoi c c'est plus
dans la société ou voilà on parle
d'accessibilité
la loi de 2005 ça fait 14 ans que tout
devrait être à peu près à peu près aux
normes et on voit que c'est toujours
compliqué on association qu'on a créé
c'est un peu ça c'est aussi un peu de
casse et tous ces codes du handicap et
de montrer que voilà toutes les
personnes en situation d'handicap
vraiment développer des projets énormes
soit dans le sport dans la culture dans
des entreprises ont un peu dans tout et
c'est c'est juste réussir voilà adapter
certaines situations dans la société ou
voilà ils peuvent vous ça peut être
compliqué comme arriver un feu qui soit
prêt sonore et ben ils ont besoin de
quelqu'un pour leur dire si c'est rouge
ou vert mais sinon ils peuvent se
débrouiller très bien tu seras où le
prêtre est proue de trith vous les deux
s'entendent bien ils vont leur relation
a eu elle est toute naturelle nous on
n'a pas fait grand chose autour de ça on
avait juste vigilant à ce que la place
de chacun soit respecté et que chacun
ait sa propre
son propos est belle pour grandir et que
tout il m'a juste orienté autour de
joaquin parce que c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il faudrait